>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANK YOU.
IT JOINING US NOW, THE GOVERNOR
OF NEBRASKA, PETE RICKETTS.
GOVERNOR, WELCOME TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY"."
>> Governor Ricketts: GOOD
MORNING, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
>> Chris: I WANT TO START WITH
SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID THIS
WEEK ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN’S NEW
VACCINE MANDATES, HERE YOU ARE,
SIR.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS FORGOTTEN
WE LIVE IN AMERICA, HE THINGS WE
LIVE IN THE SOVIET UNION AND THE
HYPOCRISY OF THIS IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Chris: GOVERNOR, WHAT’S SO
OBJECTIONABLE ABOUT BIDEN’S
VACCINE MANDATES AND WHAT ARE
YOU GOING DO ABOUT IT?
>> Governor Ricketts: WELL,
FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED.
WE’VE BEEN PROVIDING INFORMATION
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO REACH OUT
TO THEIR NEIGHBORS BECAUSE
VACCINES WORK AND THEY WILL HELP
PEOPLE.
BUT IT SHOULD BE A PERSONAL
HEALTH CARE CHOICE.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD MANDATE AND
SOMEBODY SHOULDN’T HAVE TO MAKE
THE CHOICE BETWEEN KEEPING THEIR
JOB AND GETTING A JOB IN THE
ARM.
IT’S JUST WRONG.
I’VE TALKED TO PEOPLE, A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE TOLD ME IF
THEY MADE ME TAKE THE VACCINE
I’M JUST GOING TO BE FIRED, I’M
NOT GOING TO DO IT.
>> Chris: BUT YOU SAY IT’S A
PERSONAL CHOICE.
IN FACT TO ATTEND SCHOOL IN YOUR
STATE OF NEBRASKA, CHILDREN MUST
BE VACCINATED AGAINST A NUMBER
OF DISEASES.
LET ME PUT THEM UP ON THE
SCREEN.
THEY MUST BE VACCINATED AGAINST
DIPHTHERIA, TETANUS AND
PERTUSSIS.
POLIO.
MEASLES, MUMPS, AND RUBELLA.
HEPATITIS B, AND CHICKEN POX.
WHY ARE THOSE MANDATES THAT
PARENTS AND YOUR STATE MUST
COMPLY WITH AND DO COMPLY WITH
ROUTINELY -- WHY IS IT THAT THEY
ARE NOT SO OBJECTIONABLE AND
SUCH A VIOLATION OF PERSONAL
FREEDOM BUT BIDEN APOSTATE IS
VACCINE MANDATES ARE?
>> Governor Ricketts: WELL,
FOR ALL THOSE THAT YOU JUST
LISTED, THIS A LONG HISTORY THAT
PARENTS HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE HOW THOSE THINGS HAVE
BEEN UP LAMENTED.
AND THERE’S STILL A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO DON’T KNOW
WHAT TO TRUST AND IN FACT THIS
IS REALLY AN OUTCOME OF WHAT THE
CDC HAS DONE BECAUSE THEY
FLIP-FLOPPED ON SO MANY ISSUES
WHETHER IT’S MASKS OR WHETHER
YOU HAVE TO MASK IF YOU’VE BEEN
VACCINATED AND SO FORTH.
THERE’S JUST A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO DON’T KNOW WHO TO
TRUST RIGHT NOW.
AND SO BY HAVING THE GOVERNMENT
FORCE IT ON YOU -- YOU’RE NOT
BUILDING THE TRUST WHERE WE HAVE
THE HEART TRUST WITH THOSE OTHER
VACCINES.
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT’S GOING
TO TAKE TIME TO BRING PEOPLE
ALONG, AND THAT’S WHY IT SHOULD
BE A PERSONAL CHOICE AND NOT
SOMETHING MANDATED BY THE
GOVERNMENT BURIED >> Chris:
BUT FORGIVE ME, SIR.
I’M OLD ENOUGH THAT I REMEMBER
WHEN THE POLIO VACCINE FIRST
CAME OUT.
A LOT OF US AND CERTAINLY OUR
PARENTS VIEWED IT AS A BLESSING
AND IMMEDIATELY -- I LIVED IN
NEW YORK STATE AT THAT TIME, THE
STATE MANDATED THAT WE ALL GET
THE POLIO VACCINE.
SO YOU KNOW WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC, THERE IS A NEW
VACCINE THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR.
IT’S BEEN APPROVED, FULL
APPROVAL BY THE FDA.
AGAIN, IF POLIO VACCINE IS OKAY
FOR PARENTS AND THEY HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH IT, TO SEND THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL, WHY NOT FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE, NOT JUST KIDS,
THE VACCINE FOR THIS DISEASE?
>> Governor Ricketts: I THINK
THIS IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
POLIO THAT HAS VERY DEVASTATING
EFFECTS AND CERTAINLY WE KNOW IF
YOU’RE OLDER, 65 YEARS AND
OLDER, THAT’S WERE 83% OF OUR
DEATHS IN NEBRASKA CAME FROM, WE
KNOW THIS IS REALLY DEVASTATING,
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT NEARLY 87%
OF OUR 65 YEARS AND OLDER
POPULATION HAS BEEN VACCINATED
AND IF YOU’RE LOOKING AT YOUNG
CHILDREN, FOR EXAMPLE, HERE IN
NEBRASKA, WE CAN LOOK AT THE
DATA AND SEE THAT REALLY
CHILDREN ARE AT NO MORE RISK FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS THAN THEY ARE
FOR THE ORDINARY FLU, AND SO
IT’S ALL ABOUT BALANCING OFF
THESE RISKS AND THE RISK FOR
THIS IS JUST SUCH WHERE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULDN’T BE
MANDATING IT.
AGAIN, THE WHOLE GOAL FOR ALL WE
ARE DOING AT LEAST IN NEBRASKA
HOW WE’RE DOING IT, IS AROUND
MAKING SURE WE ARE PRESERVING
HOSPITAL CAPACITY AND WE’VE
SUCCESSFULLY DONE THAT HERE.
EVEN WITHOUT DOING STATEWIDE
MASK MANDATES AND WITHOUT DOING
VACCINE PASSPORTS.
SO LET’S KEEP THE OBJECTIVE IN
MIND, WHICH IS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE AND WHICH WE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY DONE HERE IN
NEBRASKA BY PROTECTING OUR
HOSPITAL CAPACITY AND NOT HAVE
THE HEAVY HAND OF GOVERNMENT
COME IN AND TELL PEOPLE WHAT TO
DO, THEY JUST WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
ASKED ON FRIDAY ABOUT LEADERS,
GOVERNORS LIKE YOU WHO SAY THEY
ARE GOING TO CHALLENGE HIM ON
THE VACCINE MANDATES.
HERE’S WHAT HIS RESPONSE WAS.
>> President Biden: HAVE
ADDED.
LOOK, I AM SO DISAPPOINTED THAT
PARTICULARLY SOME REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN SO CAVALIER
WITH THE HEALTH OF THESE KIDS.
SO CAVALIER WITH THE HEALTH OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
>> Chris: GOVERNOR, ARE YOU
BEING CAVALIER WITH THE HEALTH
OF YOUR COMMUNITIES?
>> Governor Ricketts: WHAT
WE’RE DOING IS FOCUSING ON
PRESERVING HOSPITAL CAPACITY,
WHICH WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY DONE
HERE IN A ARE TIED FOR THE THIRD
LOWEST MORTALITY RATE OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CONTRACTED COVID-19,
AND SO WE PROTECTED THAT
HOSPITAL CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
THAT CARE.
AND AGAIN, WE CAN LOOK AT THE
DATA SPECIFICALLY AROUND
CHILDREN AND SEE THE RISKS.
AT LAST YEAR IN NEBRASKA IF YOU
WERE AGED 10-19, YOU WERE 26
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE IN A
CAR ACCIDENT THEN YOU WERE OF
COVID-19.
SO THE PRESIDENT SHOULD LOOK AT
THE DATA AND MAYBE THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD ATTEND ONE OF THE WEEKLY
CALLS IS AN ADMINISTRATION HAS
WITH ALL THE GOVERNORS.
HE HAS NOT BEEN ON ONE YET SINCE
HE’S BEEN PRESIDENT.
AND MAYBE TALK TO SOME OF THE
GOVERNORS AND ASK THEM ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON IN THEIR STATES,
BECAUSE HE APPEARS TO BE PRETTY
IGNORANT OF WHAT’S GOING ON IN
PLACES LIKE NEBRASKA.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
COVID SITUATION IN YOUR STATE,
AND AGAIN, IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT
KIDS, IT’S ABOUT THE ENTIRE
POPULATION.
IT LET ME PUT THE STATS UP ON
THE SCREEN.
BACK IN JUNE, NEBRASKA WAS
AVERAGING 23 NEW CASES A DAY.
NOW WITH THE DELTA SURGE, YOU
ARE AVERAGING 759 NEW CASES A
DAY.
GOVERNOR, THAT’S THE HIGHEST
SINCE LAST WINTER.
>> Governor Ricketts: YEAH,
AND AGAIN, WHAT WE WOKE US ON
HIS PRESERVING HOSPITAL CAPACITY
AND WE HAVE SEEN A STEADY
INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
SUMMER.
HERE IN THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER,
THE MONTH OF HOSS -- NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAS BOUNCED
AROUND BETWEEN SUIT 379 AND ON
FRIDAY DROP DOWN TO 3 OUT OF 50,
SO IT’S BEEN IN THAT RANGE FOR
MOST OF SEPTEMBER.
AND THAT IS IN CONTRAST TO THE
987 WE HAD AT OUR PEAK IN
NOVEMBER OF 2020.
SO YOU CAN SEE WE ARE WELL BELOW
WHERE WE REACHED OUR PEAK LAST
YEAR.
WE DID DECLARE A STAFFING
EMERGENCY FOR HOSPITALS TO BE
ABLE TO HELP THEM MANAGE THEIR
FOLKS, YOU KNOW, TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO BRING IN NURSES AND SO
FORTH, BUT WHAT WE FOCUS ON IS
PROVIDING THE HOSPITAL CAPACITY.
WE SET UP A TRANSFER CENTER TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE PEOPLE AROUND
BETWEEN HOSPITALS STATEWIDE AND
ALL THAT TO MAKE SURE WE’RE
PROTECTING THE HOSPITAL
CAPACITY, AND THAT’S OUR GUIDING
STAR HERE IN NEBRASKA.
AND WE’VE DONE A VERY
SUCCESSFULLY, AS I INDICATED
WITH OUR SUCCESS IN KEEPING
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, FROM DYING
FROM THIS DISEASE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO TALK TO
ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE I LOOKED
INTO THE SITUATION, THE STRESS
ON HOSPITAL STAFFING AND
HOSPITAL BEDS AND THE FACT IS,
ON SEPTEMBER 1ST, YOU ANNOUNCED
YOUR STATE WAS OPENING A
HOSPITAL TRANSFER CENTER THAT
WOULD ALLOW PATIENTS TO BE MOVED
AROUND IN CASE THERE WASN’T
ENOUGH STAFF OR BEDS IN ONE
PLACE.
YOU ALSO HAVE DIRECTED HEALTH
MEASURES TO LIMIT ELECTIVE
SURGERIES AND ONE OF YOUR TOP
HEALTH OFFICIALS SAYS THE FACT
IS THERE ISN’T ENOUGH ROOM IN
YOUR HOSPITALS BY THE END OF
EACH DAY FOR HIGH-LEVEL CARE.
>> Governor Ricketts: ACTUALLY
WHAT WE’VE DONE IS MOVE THE
PEOPLE AROUND IF WE NEEDED TO,
THAT’S WHAT THE TRANSFER CENTER
IS FOR, TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
HOSPITALS WHO WANT TO MOVE A
PATIENT TO GET MORE ACUTE CARE,
TO BE ABLE TO OFFICIALLY MOVE
THAT PERSON INTO HOSPITAL.
THIS PRIMARILY HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GOT SAY MORE RURAL HOSPITAL
SETTINGS, MAY NOT HAVE ALL THE
FACILITIES THAT MAYBE SOME OF
OUR URBAN CENTERS DO.
AND ALLOW THEM TO OFFICIALLY GET
THAT TO THE RIGHT HOSPITAL.
AND CERTAINLY WE ARE ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO GET
VACCINATED AS PART OF THIS, BUT
WE ARE MANAGING OUR HOSPITAL
CAPACITY VERY SUCCESSFULLY HERE
IN THIS STATE WITH THE TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED THE
STAFFING EMERGENCY.
>> Chris: I ASKED YOUR
QUESTION AT THE TOP, I ASK YOU
WHY IT WAS SO OBJECTIONABLE, YOU
ANSWER THAT.
YOU DIDN’T ANSWER THE OTHER
QUESTION.
LET’S FINISH WITH THAT, WERE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S VACCINE
MANDATES?
>> Governor Ricketts: YEAH, SO
I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO MY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE’S COORDINATING WITH THE OTHER
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO SHARE SIMILAR VIEWS
ABOUT THE OVERREACH, THIS IS A
EGREGIOUS OVERREACH OF FEDERAL
AUTHORITY.
AND AS WE SEE WITH THESE RULES
ARE, WE WILL BE ABLE TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO
CHALLENGE THEM IN COURT.
I’M ALSO TALKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE COUNTRY AS
WELL, THE OTHER GOVERNORS WHO
FEEL THE WAY I DO, AND WE WILL
BE WORKING ON OTHER STRATEGIES,
BUT I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, I HAVE
HEARD FROM SO MANY WORKERS, SO
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES WHO SAY
THIS IS JUST NOT GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT CAN HANDLE.
SUMMATIVE PEOPLE TOLD ME THEY’RE
JUST GOING TO BE FIRED IF THEY
ARE FORCED TO TAKE THE VACCINE.
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO CREATE
HUGE PROBLEMS FOR ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES AND FOR OUR AMERICAN
WORKERS AND AGAIN, YOU SHOULDN’T
HAVE TO MAKE THE CHOICE OF
KEEPING HER JOB OR GETTING A JOB
IN THE ARM.
>> Chris: VERY BRIEFLY, YOU
SAY YOU’RE GOING TO COURT.
ANY IDEA HOW SOON?
>> Governor Ricketts: WELL,
WHEN WE GET AN IDEA OF WHAT
THESE ROLES EXECUTIVE WILL BE,
WE WILL KNOW HOW TO BE ABLE TO
ATTACK IT IN COURT.
>> Chris: GOVERNOR RICKETTS,
THANK YOU, THANK SPARE TIME